John Farrell let her known as Jack
author of the book Richard Nixon to life
at the very end of your book in the
footnotes at the end the source notes
you say this he hoped that Billy Graham
or norman vincent peale would handle the
prayers this is that is general and
quote doesn't want a Catholic or a Jew
to participate this comes from a
Haldeman comment what was what was that
all about this is that his journal yes
yeah Nixon came from a very provincial
background we think of Southern
California now as highways and
subdivisions but when he was growing up
it was the outback
it was orange groves and hills and very
small towns in between and he grew up
with a certain provincial bigotry I
think he got some of it from his father
who was a unlearned man and over the
years
Nixon learned to deal with it because he
had to Nixon could do almost anything if
he had to and so he had great advisers
like Len garment Henry Kissinger Arthur
burns who were Jewish but in private
against his enemies who happened to be
Jewish
he could be very ugly and I think that
this was sort of a blanket statement
Haldeman had his own biases and perhaps
he took it down a little bit more
severely than it sounds but Nixon
definitely he wanted a Protestant
mainstream white American Barilla I
found the last hundred twenty pages
where they were source notes they
weren't a part of the narrative in your
book with some of the most interesting
stuff and I and anybody watching usually
people are older that watch this kind of
a program
they're going to know who Richard Nixon
was and all that so I'm not going to try
to go through in the details so that's
why I'm focusing on this Shin with that
in mind if I want you to hear something
that you know about of course from one
of the tapes first of all ask you did a
whole woman know that the Richard Nixon
had a taping system Haldeman and a
couple of others
Secret Service technicians were the only
ones
the reason I ask that is you'll see
because this is Haldeman and President
Nixon talking in the Oval Office in 1971
and you got it we've got it on the
screen so listen carefully bail burgers
populist loud
[Music]
whether our truth
nourish a few of those and let's review
economies if they do the likely the
names of these are active site and they
show one of the Negro's you address
granting legal size and intellectual a
smart in the SRT file select all of the
Jews are our orange lies you know
somebody burn disk in it was up there
next look at it basic he is it would be
isness well on Harris areas that cover
makes you know he was installed I have a
silent pain I talk about massages would
have because ideas now they both know
that they were on day but what in the
world are they talking about that for it
is they're on tape but it would take far
too much intellectual concentration and
effort to talk all the time for the tape
recorder
and he was confident that it could
maintain control on he had been
Eisenhower's vice president and he had
seen hidin tower and Truman before them
make vast claims of executive privilege
so he thought that he would be able to
safeguard his tapes and his papers
forever and nobody else would ever hear
about them
the bad part about the tapes is that
they're ramblings they're spewing their
nixon talking off the top of the head
they don't show any of the positive
signs of nixon and they are forever
going to be this huge millstone around
his neck because every time somebody
tries to write something nice about him
and say well you know this was a decent
president you look what I did for the
environment look at he proposed this
visionary health care plan
he created the Environmental Protection
Agency and then somebody's going to play
one of these tapes and it's going to you
know drop them back down on the
the unlisted present it's a it's it's
it's very revealing it's fantastic for a
historian we have two or three
presidencies in a row where we have
Kennedy Johnson and Nixon caught on tape
talking to their aides nothing like this
ever before came ajan if you had
Washington and Jefferson and Hamilton
talking on tape in the cabinet but this
so but they but they will forever be a
just a hindrance to the rehabilitation
of Richard Nixon how long's it's
definitely how long did you work on this
book six years from start to publication
why did you do it I did it because I had
a very smart editor at doubleday who
looked five years into the future and
said I think that five years from now
people are going to be ready with all
the new stuff that's coming out and with
this whole new audience of Millennials
and Gen Xers there's going to be an
interest to find out who Nixon is and to
have a one-volume Nixon and Doubleday of
his name is Bill Thomas he came to me
and he asked me whether I would like to
do it and I said took me about five
seconds to say yes in your
acknowledgments in this book which is a
law large book it's got over what close
to 700 pages but if you only want to
read the text the text is only 500
minutes you can write it on the beach
yeah it's aimed at people who want to
read this the whole story in a readable
way and then I had to do the 200 pages
of footnotes because I knew that
historians journalists at academics
would would insist to see where this
stuff came from but also because there's
lots of interesting questions that you
answer that are that are subtleties that
the average reader when they want to
read a story about dick and Pat and
Julie in the war and Watergate are not
going to want to get into a five or six
page debate over you know what the world
the CIA was in Watergate so I save that
for the footnote in your acknowledgments
you start off with this paragraph saying
Steven Ambrose writing during the next
in his lifetime took three volumes to
tell a story of the 37th president and
then you list all that's new which I'll
go over in a second ask you about it but
how many books like this on the whole
life of Richard Nixon have been been
written
in the turn of the century I think
there's only one person who has tried to
do a well-rounded biography and that was
Evan Thomas everybody else wrote in the
1990s and they were they were good books
you go back and read them now you're
it's amazing how much they were able to
get to the essence of the man and find
revealing stuff with several of them he
cooperated but people like Tom wicker he
didn't cooperate yet they still managed
to have a very good perspective on it in
this list and you have a long list of
things that have come since Stephen
Ambrose and you say he did he did not
have access to any but a few of the 3700
hours of White House tape recordings did
you how much of those did you listen to
or read about oh how much fortunately
there are three or four massive books of
transcripts and several places online
the Miller Center at the University of
Virginia and also look Nick Turse
website Nixon tapes where there's lots
of transcripts you don't have to listen
to everything then this two ways to
listen one is to listen for Greatest
Hits and other ways is just to pick a
day and listen through so there were
points where I picked a day and listened
through so the spring of 1973
I picked January first and I listened
through April the Pentagon Papers days I
did that that month in the summer of
1971 other than that I around because
it's they're very hard to listen to the
ones that are in the Oval Office are on
the telephone or crystal clear but the
ones in the executive office building
his hideaway office
clattering cups he murmurs he turns away
from the microphone just a bad
technological setup and so it's much
more frustrating again on the list the
four hundred oral history interviews of
Nixon's friends and families conducted
by Whittier colleagues when did that
become public I became I think it's in
there but it's just within the last two
or three years and what was unique about
the winter colleagues oral histories it
was great because Whittier was where he
went to college and they went out and
they talked to all his old Quaker Quaker
relatives all the old neighbors from
Yorba Linda where he grew up on the farm
all the people who use the store in
Whittier that his father ran on the
highway outside of town and so it was I
think I hope that the opening chapters
that capture the early Richard Nixon and
the formation of his character are made
far far richer because of these oral
histories they're just a huge treasure
trove try to come back to this of course
but Nixon's grand jury testimony from
the Alger Hiss and Watergate cases how
did that become public and when I think
both of them were the resort were the
result of court decisions I know the
Nixon one was I'm the the Alger Hiss one
is fantastic because it's very
contentious debate over whether this was
a spy and what Nixon's motives were and
lots of questions about what happened
when in the in the progression and here
you have Nixon and Whittaker Chambers
who was the person who accused Alger
Hiss of being a spy and hiss and all the
congressional aides and investigators
all called before grand jury and you
know told to raise their hand on the
penalty of perjury and saying exactly
what they did over the previous six
months so it's it's to me contemporary
testimony given under oath is about the
best you're going to get it as an
historian far better than memoirs a
reminisce is 20 years later what are
your conclusions about Alger Hiss I
think absolutely it was a spot where you
ever a doubter going into what I had to
try to keep an open mind but I had
happened to have a neighbor in
Kensington who wrote some of the books
about the Venona project which was a
secret American eavesdropping case where
they broke the Russian code and found
traces that showed that that I found one
time no no we can look at that okay yes
another thing on the list HR Haldeman
Diaries or the transcriptions of Henry
Kissinger's White House telephone
conversations all of which have since
been opened to scholars and when did you
see that and that and did you use those
sources again Nixon is so wonderful to
do as a biographer because there's
nothing more revelation more revealing
than Haldeman s diary which he kept
faithfully every night and wrote down
almost
everything that happened during the day
and what Nixon said and what Nixon's
mood was during the day and then you
have Henry Kissinger who has his
brilliant analytical mind and it's a
wonderful writer and put together three
volumes of memoirs almost immediately
after he he left government service and
so they're just magical sources that and
and you could just go back to them time
and time and time again what book is is
for you
third the third the first two were about
I did a biography of speaker Tip O'Neill
and then I did a biography of the great
defense attorney Clarence Darrow where
do you go to school University Virginia
where'd you grow up
Huntington New York and then Rockville
Maryland how long did you work for the
Denver Post I worked for the Denver Post
twice each time five years stints I
worked out there in Denver for five
years I went to the Boston Globe for
almost 20 years
and then I came back and worked for the
Denver Post in Washington and how long
have you not worked for a newspaper
since about 2003 I think the buyouts
began the newspaper industry began to to
crater and I had had the first book
under my belt and decided that I would
try to do this full-time in your book
you make a particular point of the
importance of the following comment that
Richard Nixon made and the David Frost
Nixon interviews back in 1977 this is
only 25 seconds I don't go with the idea
that there was that what brought me down
was a coup conspiracy etcetera etcetera
etcetera I brought myself down I gave
him a sword and they stuck it in and
they twisted it with Rajesh and I guess
if I had been in their position I'd have
done the same thing
from what you learned how long did it
take David price to get to that point
that was at the end or almost to the end
of the interviews because Nixon opened
up the interviews almost like a
filibuster I mean I think the first
question that Frost asked was about the
tapes and then he went into Vietnam and
Nixon just talked on and on and on and
it was great frustration on the frost
side that they weren't
pinning pinning him down I think they
knew that was they were going to get to
Watergate
they knew they didn't want to be
filibustered the way he had done it on
Vietnam and and frost does this
wonderfully dramatic thing where he
takes his clipboard and puts it down on
the ground you can see it in the tape
and says mr. president you know I'm
going to put this aside I'm just going
to let you have a chance to to say
something that you're going to be very
sorry if you don't have if you don't
really say this and come to grips with
what you've done to the American people
it's a great great movement not as great
as the final goodbye in the East Room of
the White House that I think is one of
the greatest moments of American
political history bar none did you ever
meet him Richard no I did not the
closest I got was as I opened one
chapter on his inauguration he's driving
down Pennsylvania Avenue with open-top
limousine waving to the crowds and all
of a sudden there's a bunch of anti-war
protestors start throwing cans and and
rocks and they had to button Nixon back
up inside the limo and so his presidency
got off to a rocky start because of
Vietnam and I was there as a not as a
proctor rehearsal spectator in the crowd
and that was the only time I ever saw
him in person
Frank Nixon his father you have a lot in
your book about him where did you learn
it mostly from the oral histories from
Whittier there's another set of oral
histories from California State
University at forcin and it's amazing
how many times you come across the word
belligerent stubborn rude just was
sounded to be a very unpleasant man and
and Richard Nixon was a very sensitive
guy and very sensitive child had two
brothers died in as a youth and I think
that he in some ways was bruised by by
that dad the fella named Rick Pearlstein
wrote a book called Nixon land and in it
he talks about the very sturdy political
trope that all politicians are trying to
prove that they're as good as their
saintly mother believes they are in the
face of skeptic
them from a father for whom they can
never win his approval so how did you go
about doing this I mean physically where
were you it's a nightmare if I had
gotten the contract three years earlier
I could have done all the research 30
minutes from my house everything was at
the National Archives in Greenbelt
Maryland and in those three years before
I got the contract everything was packed
up and moved to your Berlin to
California to the Nixon what was then
the Nixon private library and now has
become a national archives library and
so I spent lots of time in the extended
stay motel in Yorba Linda so of all the
things that you've got access to what
what probably either change your mind or
made the biggest impact on you the
biggest news nugget was finding that
you've had Robert Caroline who does
that's a great series of books on Lyndon
Johnson and he gave me great advice that
somebody had one of his old crusty
editors are given him which is turn
every page and when you get what you
think could be a good vein keep going
even though you're finding nothing great
and several years ago I think about 2007
something that Nixon had fought for
years to keep private which is his
personal and political papers from the
campaign's were finally released to the
public and they set out there in Yorba
Linda and if you go through them there
you know page after page of Haldeman
saying you know ok this is how we're
going to deal with the bumper sticker so
this is what the polls show in Alabama
or this is where we're going to go next
week and but if you keep turning the
pages as as Bob told me I came across
the section of notes that hold him in
Captain but what he used to do is he
would sit down with Nixon like you and I
are except Holloman would have a yellow
pad and everything the Nixon would tell
him to do
Haldeman write down on the yellow pad
and then he would make the phone calls
to put the machinery in operation and he
put a big checkmark next to it when it
was done and so here was a yellow pad
where Alderman writes down
in the midst of the October 1968 we're
going to Monkeywrench
Lyndon Johnson's peace initiative this
is something that had always been
rumored and bits of pieces had come out
over the years but Nixon denied it at
the time to Lyndon Johnson and he denied
it to David Frost and he denied it to
his biographers always said that he had
never played any role in doing this but
in fact he had used a go-between a
campaign aide named Anna Chennault and
had her communicate to the South
Vietnamese that they would get a better
deal if they held back from the peace
process and he got elected and they did
he got elected and the war went on now
it probably went too far there to leave
the impression that the war would not
have gone on if he hadn't done this we
don't know that but certainly LBJ's
thought there was a decent chance that a
peace deal was possible and whatever
Nixon did to disrupt it I make the
argument in the book that this was far
worse than Watergate giving both great
loss of life they follow in your notes
long long efforts no but in here ship
you know and your source entities say
that and I shouldn't wanted a job and
didn't get it yeah yeah I did where did
you find that you mean again that there
was a whole section of not just Haldeman
scrawled notes reflecting his
conversation with Nixon but also it
shows a sort of degree of self
consciousness because Haldeman had
collected all the additional stuff
together so they were emmos and there
were there were time slips showing the
number of phone calls that went back and
forth between the Nixon campaign and
Anna and it all been nicely put aside
and Nixon's lawyers had made sure that
we didn't see it for four years this
again I'm this is a lot of personal
stuff and I found it new but it's in
from other books that you also went to
but this is one is from historian erlin
gilman and you say positive things about
professor Erlin Gulman as one of them
are foremost one of the foremost
authorities on Richard Nixon who is he
irva this wonderful man who has taken it
upon himself to write Richard Nixon's
history in
in politics starting with a book called
The Contender and then he just did a
book called The Apprentice in the
Francis and the President or the
president the apprentice in the
president about Nixon's vice
presidential years and he probably has
gone through you know you asked me how
many pages I've gone through will curve
has probably gone through three or four
times as many as I did and he knows the
collection in yer bilenda backwards and
forwards he's a wonderful guy great help
to me and other Nicks and authors who
invariably are told well you know I went
to ask her where that kind of stuff is
and we do and he's gracious and he helps
us and what would you put him on the
list of people that have the importance
of the people of done books on Richard
Nixon given good health and and he and
he fulfills his goal which is to
chronicle all the way through the end of
the presidency I think this will be
something comparable to Carole's work
here is this is from his book as you
mentioned the presidency and apprentice
and this is all this is very old stuff
that goes back to the 50s Gulman notes
Nixon was taking three equal the
tranquilizer during the day he was also
taking DEXA mill a stimulant that could
elevate mood and lead to psychic
dependence during the evening he had two
or three drinks before going to sleep he
had half a Dora Dhin a potentially
addictive drug for those who had trouble
sleeping his visions also prescribed the
barbiturates second all seekin all or
second all in the 1950s and early 1960s
these and other medicines were often
prescribed for depression sleeplessness
and fatigue it's heavy stuff well two
things one is Nixon was a very tightly
wound guy and in the in the 50s he was
treated rather badly by Eisenhower and
so he was always worried he his rise was
so quick he went from nobody to the vice
presidency in six years and he was
overwhelmed by it and and throwing it to
this huge battle between Eisenhower and
Joe McCarthy so it's not a surprise that
he took to self-medicating himself or
going to doctors when he had these
symptoms of tension and and being
prescribed these medicines
on the other hand if you remember the
famous Jacqueline Susann novel Valley of
the dolls in the 50s and 60s this is
what Americans did they took a lot they
popped a lot of pills and they drank a
lot all the presidents before Nixon
we're very proud of their of their
ability to drink or to mix a cocktail
for their guests so drinking and the use
of tranquilizers and sleeping pills very
much more I think as common then as
maybe the anti-anxiety drugs are today
you know I'm reading from the source
notes at what point and the process did
you write all these source notes I made
this I may keep making the same mistake
over and over again which is not doing
them while I write the book and then I
find that I have to dig back through the
files and because I think that I've done
enough on a footnote then I find out
that it didn't exactly get the date
right on that particular letter and I
have to go back and do it over again so
each time I get a little bit better at
it the next book I swear to myself I'm
going to have them all done when the
text is done it seemed to me that this
was unusual your source notes that they
were more narrative than normal and
longer than normal were you aware that
when you're writing I like that and I
have a direct editor Chris Pablo who
encourages me to do that she likes that
too it's for people who like the extra
what's the the phrase in New Orleans
line up the extra little taste after you
finished the book and go back through
there you can find out about the CIA a
little bit more about Watergate more
about Nixon's father and it fills out
stuff without blocking the narrative
here's a note on page 684 to the reports
Nixon was fortifying himself with liquor
that fall his daughter Julie said this
the drinking rumors were the most
persistent perhaps because it seemed he
was drinking a little more than ever he
had before but at dinner time when he
was trying to unwind
he still adhered to his self-imposed
code of no alcohol on nights he was
attending receptions or dinners nor did
he drink during the day and then you go
on the next page to include this on
alcohol cito Kahn
meaning telephone conversation when
Kissinger and Snow Croft on October 11th
I said the switchboard just got a call
from 10 Downing Street to inquire
whether the president would be available
for a call within 30 minutes from the
Prime Minister the subject was to be the
Middle East
Kissinger can we tell them no when I
talked to the president he was loaded
where did that come from I mean how do
you how do you get access to that
telephone conversation that was a result
of a court case filed to get these
Kissinger telecoms as they're called I
think it was filed by the National
Security Archive
or maybe Public Citizen but they got
access to thousands of pages of what
what would happen is when Kissinger is
national security advisor would have a
conversation with a foreign leader he
would have a secretary on the phone
taking down notes and this was a common
practice that went back through as long
as there's been telephones but Kissinger
fought very hard he wanted them kept
under his control throughout his
lifetime
these good government organizations went
to court and they filed suit and they
won access to again it within the last
decade how extensive was the drinking it
was a problem Winston Lord who probably
I you know if I had to pick one person
on the great scale of reliability he was
one in Len garment was another I mean
justice Harlow was a third people that
when they spoke to me or just that it
was either that I agreed with them
exactly or they spoke such sense that I
was over I was overwhelmed by listening
to them and Winston Lord in a
marvelously long oral history that he
gave said yeah it was absolutely a
problem
we shouldn't over exaggerate it but it
was a problem how many how many people
were you able to talk to they were close
to Richard Nixon
I talked to probably a dozen one of the
problems is is that I'll tell you a
story I talked to Mel Laird who was his
secretary of defense and as I'm talking
to Mel Mel I said well you know you were
a close friend of Jerry Ford who
exceeded Nixon and pardoned him and
you're a close friend of Nixon and did
you play any role in Nixon's resignation
and he said oh yeah yeah yeah he said I
told Nixon that he would be pardoned
now everybody and their brother has
denied throughout the years that there
was any deal between Jerry and dick but
if he resigned he would he would be
pardoned and here was Mel Laird
in his mid-90s telling me this and I
asked him tell me it again he told me it
again and finally the third time I said
okay you know mr. Laird you know you're
telling me something that's going to be
very controversial because there's
always both presidents always insisted
that there wasn't a deal and now you're
telling me that you were conveying word
that Nixon was going to get a pardon if
he resigned and Laird stopped me hello I
it I wasn't conveying word from Jerry I
talked to the two of them and this was
my conclusion that I predicted so what
do you do with that then do you do you
put that in the book and you make it a
selling point that you've gotten proof
of a deal or do you realize that a 95
year old man doing his best to remember
these things over the years having
written a memoir which doesn't say this
at all may have been mistaken let me
jump in with another source note on
another page pardoned by Ford on the
same issue after consulting with Nixon
Hegg advice Ford more than a week before
the resignation that the president
expected to step down gave him a whole
week at the same meeting ahead presented
Ford with the option of pardoning Nixon
Ford seemed amenable Haig then went back
to Nixon and gave him a report on the
conversation Nixon subsequently resigned
but both Haig and Ford insist no
explicit quid pro quo was struck where
did you find that I think I think there
were lots of not nods and wings I think
everybody knew what was had a good idea
about what was going to going to happen
and in fact there was a big there was a
congressional investigation after after
the pardon and all of Nixon excuse me
all of Ford's aids over then and since
have all testified to this meeting
between Ford and Haig and exactly what
happened and how after Jerry finished
talking with hey they all went to in the
semi-god
you can't say that you've got to call
him back and say you're not all dangling
a pardon it's a big long convoluted
history so the simplicity of what Mel
told me was that oh yeah I was a
go-between a knight I passed the word
insurance to dick that he would be
pardoned would have been a nice new
piece but you know you asked me how many
of the people that were close to Nixon I
talked to I wasn't quite as enthusiastic
I wasn't quite a diligent and going out
and talking to these old guys because I
questioned basically their memory it
mean having done the book about Clarence
Darrow I have a great skepticism about
testimony from from memory and by the
way do Tip O'Neill Clarence Darrow and
Richard Nixon which was the most fun
interesting you know tips always the
oldest towel so I'm always going to like
tip Clarence Darrow like I just adored
the personality of the man and Nixon was
by far the most fascinating it's just a
great intellectual challenge and also I
grew I mean you cannot be honest and go
to Richard Nixon's life and not have
much more sympathy for him because he
really did have a tough life and he
really was trying to be a good guy and
and yet he had this part of his
character this great Shakespearean fatal
flaw that that brought him down this is
from your source notes politicians have
been known to exaggerate this is you
saying this now politicians have been
known to exaggerate and Nixon was a
veteran liar definitely he once told Len
garment Glenn you're never going to
succeed in politics because you're just
not a good enough liar Nixon was a great
high school debater and in high school
debate you have to end college debater
and you have to take both sides of an
argument you have to be able to stand up
one day or one round and argue the
positive and then later that day you
have to be able to argue the negative
and it gives you a such a flexibility of
mind and such a willingness to see that
the facts can be turned in your
advantage and Nixon throughout his
political career was one of the best at
that I've always liked trying to see how
his actions could be explained in a way
that would turn the tables on the other
guy and and if it's that meant line then
that meant line here's another one from
resource notes i leaked everything Nixon
told Henry Kissinger and a Haldeman July
of 1971 convict the SOB in the press
that's the way it's done yeah that was
during the Pentagon Papers case Daniel
Ellsberg a whistleblower had taken the
secret history of the Vietnam War and he
had given it to the New York Times and
the great irony there and the great
revealing thing about that story is that
it didn't go up to the Nixon years it
just was about the Johnson years in the
Kennedy years it was awful on the
Democrats and their first instant at the
White House was leave it alone let the
Democrats tear themselves apart over
this and yet Nixon because it was the
time it's because it was a threat to his
further conduct of the war because
Kissinger egged him on he just launched
himself into this fight they didn't have
to fight he lost it and in the process
he had this big anti leaking drive that
brought in this group of men called the
plumbers into his White House and it was
those same plumbers who ended up being
the guys caught at the Watergate as I
said at the beginning this is not meant
to be an interview from start to finish
I'm jumping around all the time I just
tell that to folks think run by your
book and get the whole story but this is
another thing that I didn't had not
heard Nixon was offered again source
notes Nixon was offered the chairmanship
of the Dreyfus Corporation and a chance
to serve as Commissioner of Major League
Baseball see Nixon Gannon meaning the
interviews between Frank Gannon Richard
Nixon he got $60,000 advance for six
crises is one of his books when before
he was elected president of which 20,000
was paid to the researcher writer Alvin
Moscow one of the several aides who
helped him Dreyfuss corporation did the
Dreyfuss clippers he was he was friends
with mr. Dreyfus and his name was first
name escapes me right now
and more interesting things to that one
is that I'm preparing a speech I have to
give in Boston at Fenway Park and it's
going to be about Nixon in sports Nixon
was a huge sports fan and there's this
one great moment in the midst of the
Watergate crisis where a reporter asks
him at a press conference or in a chance
encounter who he thinks the greatest
baseball players of all time were and
Nixon launches himself at Camp David and
pulls out all the there's no internet in
those days so he pulled out the books
with all the batting averages and and he
makes not one list but two lists one is
his before integration and the second
one is after integration after the
baseball was integrated by his one-time
good friend Jackie Robinson one hundred
Thompson who hated him the the gonzo
writer who hated Nixon over politics
once did a car ride in his limousine
with Nixon and they talked football the
whole time and and that afternoon or in
the next dispatch Hunter Thompson wrote
boy you know he's not so bad a guy he
really knows you know what linebackers
do and what makes a good line burger
versus a good safety and he seems to
have mellowed and and so anyway Nixon in
sports is fascinating he probably would
have been far overqualified to be
Commissioner of baseball but it was in
which is why he turned it down no doubt
you also said that he got $600,000 in
the frost interviews that he did that
was a very long time ago in the 70s but
then this footnote money was momentarily
an issue when still in office Nixon told
Ehrlichman that writing a book was quote
unquote agony but the corporate law was
degrading and the idea of a former
president accepting honorary ins for
speeches or for going on television is
abhorrent to me it's very it is very
ironic that the president who's most
known or maybe not most of them but it's
often known for that wonderful clip
where he says I'm not a crook people
have the right to know their president
is not a crook well I'm not a crook
was also had these incredibly high
standards when he left office he did
have a reverence for the office probably
because
he had he revered Ike and he had watched
Eisenhower be president but there were
things that he was that he was not going
to do because they would they would
tarnish the off the office and that was
one of them he never took a he never
took money for paid speeches here's
another story that you recount from his
in the arena book spun an egregious
whopper apparently seeking to secure
himself a place among the Vietnam
veterans who claim to have been spit at
when they returned home from the war do
you remember that story yeah the story
has told it in the arena was that he
went to Williamsburg Virginia for a
conference and while he was there this
young girl came up to him her face
consumed with hate and broke through the
Secret Service and and spat at him in
the face and that was his recollection
in in the arena and I went looking for
it I couldn't find it in all of the news
coverage of that trip and so I figured
that you know maybe it happened in
private but probably didn't happen at
all and then I found a memo from Pat
Buchanan sort of a memo to the record
which described not a young girl but a
young man shouting from the crowd how
does it feel to be a war criminal and in
Williamsburg had this conference and so
I mean I think that when we talked about
Nixon lying and exaggerating that's a
great example of how what actually
happened planted a little seed in his
brain that over over time became a
bigger and grander and conveniently put
him with the returning POWs and the
veterans of Vietnam as having been the
victim of being spat on has anybody else
from your research in the last 50 years
or so lied from the presidency besides
Richard Nixon absolutely in fact you
know we had three of the most amazing
presidencies in a row you know 100 years
ago I think they're all going to be
grouped together as the Cold War
President and they'll all be ranked as
to how good they did and since we're
still sitting here we're not incinerated
radioactive ash they did a good job and
they you know all together they
protected us they
made these huge swings back and forth
did some horribly aberrational things
like you know hiring them off Jack
Kennedy hiring the Mafia to try to
assassinate Fidel Castro the full report
of the church committee which went into
the history of administration after
administration had spied on Americans
opened their mails tailed them bug
bugged their telephones and not just you
know not just the mob but but you know
peace activists people like John Lennon
and even Richard Nixon when he was out
of office was was was spied on by one of
these one of these programs so I think
that that people will look back and they
will say okay they were under tremendous
pressure and there were these awful
things but you know Lincoln suspended
tapes corpus during the Civil War and
Adams signed the Alien and Sedition Acts
so you know at times of crisis
presidents maybe we can make excuse this
behavior but I mean in in the case of
just veracity and and morality I don't
think that you when you look at
Roosevelt Truman Eisenhower Kennedy
Johnson and Nixon that there's this a
huge bit of difference as to what they
would do to advance their own political
future and to protect the country he was
here 25 years ago on book notes and I
had a question about the media and his
attitude and then you've got a
interesting source and I'm going to ask
you about a month let's watch that and
then we'll delve into this more did you
ever ask yourself why so many in the
media are against you oh they didn't
agree with what I stood for so this is
long before Watergate the his case
particularly was very difficult for the
media they all thought he was innocent
and that they didn't think it was
innocent they didn't want him exposed
because it as one individual said he
said it would be a reflection on the on
the foreign policy the of the Roosevelt
administration which of course was not
my goal at all and so with that it was
difficult not that I didn't have
many friends in the media but media
people while they try to be objective
many of them do they also has strong
convictions and frankly they are they
generally are not particularly enamored
with the Conservatives as I am even
though I'm probably a more reasonable
than some of the Conservatives that they
go after anything I really can't argue
with any word that he said except he
doesn't tell the whole story it's a
fascinating relationship and I and
several times during the narrative I
break and I do a couple of pages about
where where he stands right that at that
moment because it really did twist his
perception that really did feed his
paranoia over the years but what was
really interesting is that he first ran
in Southern California as a conservative
and at that time the Los Angeles Times
was was the conservative voice in the
country and dominated Southern
California politics and they heavily
promoted him all the way up into the
Senate the United States Senate so he
had a very jaundiced view about a free
press a free press to him was they were
either for me and they're going to
advance my career because they're
conservative or they're against me and
the Liberals were going to tear me down
because of that I think that's reflected
a little bit of it back to your source
notes peg 6:32 this is a little
complicated but years later amid the
Watergate scandal Republican chairman
George HW Bush produced affidavits
alleging the Democrats ought to
eavesdrop on Nixon's hotel room before
the second presidential debate the
evidence was inconclusive but it would
not have been terribly unusual
throughout the 1950s and the 1960s
electronic eavesdropping was viewed as
somewhat under handed but trudging but a
trifling offense CBS had bugged the
closed-door sessions of the credentials
committee at the 1952 Republican
convention journalist Jack Anderson was
caught bugging during the Sherman Adams
case and NBC newsmen admitted they
bugged a private
of the Democratic platform committee in
1968 Herald Lipsett the chief
investigator for the Watergate committee
resigned from that role after someone
remembered that he had been convicted
for an illegal bug bug bugging in 1968
all these incidents were quickly
forgotten and where did you find all
that Nixon's defenders over the years
have attempted from time to time to
assemble collections of past misdeeds to
show that Nixon was the victim of a
double standard and I think the argument
is very well taken but he cared like he
carried everything I think a step
further a step too far and and he wasn't
frankly he wasn't this as good at it I
mean all these people got caught so they
weren't very good at it either but the
way that the Watergate burglars were
their team was assembled was clumsy they
were they were cynical burnt-out former
intelligence or FBI agents who were
supervised by young men on Nixon staff
who just wanted to be as one of the
famous quotes ago the cat that brought
the dead mouse to the to the president's
door so they're all eager for
advancement all trying to be more much
of than the next guy amazing thing about
all of Watergate is that it was about
something as small as a bugging compared
to that history that you just read which
was sort of accepted practice but that J
Edgar Hoover saw that times were
changing and that these kind of
practices were not going to be seen in
the 60s the way that over the 70s the
way had been seen in that in earlier
years and Hoover pulled back and said
now we're going to know we're not going
to do these black back jobs anymore and
so that's what led Nixon to have to
bring that capability in-house and in
the end got him into such trouble did
you talk to either one of his daughters
it didn't talk to either one of his
daughters Julie was very nice and that
every once in a while I would just find
something where I just had to have an
answer that only she would know and I
would send her an email and
she would in most cases she would write
back and she would say there's a famous
photograph in there at the Eisenhower
inaugural where David Eisenhower was
there with his grandfather and Julie's
there with her dad and David is looking
at her it's very cute consider knowing
the history that years later that they
would fall in love and marry and I just
had to write her and say what was going
on and she said well I he's not looking
at me the way you think he's looking at
me he's look at me because I had been in
a sledding accident I had this big black
eye and he was just sort of staring at
this little girl with a big black eye
and if you look very carefully in the
photo you can see that she did have a
shiner so it's a she Julie was very
gracious doing that she loaned me a
picture for the book of of Nixon after
in his exile years and the three Nixon
women I think if you go to the
dictionary lookup long-suffering their
pictures should be there their mom and
and Julian Japan and Tricia I wish I can
understand their paranoia at the way
they're that they have seeing how their
father has been treated but they really
could do much better to follow the
example of the Truman family the Truman
family opened up the vaults to Harry
Harry Truman's letters to his wife David
McCullough went in there and wrote a
book that instantly elevated Harry
Truman ten steps up the presidential
ladder and will be forever this great
Valentine Harry Truman and someday they
will do that and someday somebody will
write a book better than mine because it
will have Nixon's Diaries more from
Nixon's Diaries it will have more
letters to from Julian and and Tricia
but right now they're still they're
still pretty burnt and they still have a
no interview no no help why in your
opinion is Julie talked more than Tricia
I think it's a case of personality
there's a wonderful conversation that on
the tapes were Nixon and Haldeman are
analyzing the true personality and I may
agree that Julie and her way is so
bubbly and such a nice person that the
country loves her whereas Tricia is more
of a pristine beauty
and and and Nixon says yeah Oh Tricia is
more like like me more contained more
alone and and Julius the one with the
million-dollar personality my understand
I don't think that's entirely true but
that's the way the perception my
understanding is that Edward Nixon his
youngest brother is still alive and I
think I saw you quote him in here and
one of the notes did you meet with him
nothing nothing was I mean having said
what I just said about Mel Laird and the
other ninety year old guys nothing was
more important to me than that day I
spent with with Ed Nixon because first
of all he looks like dick and you and he
walks like dick and you get a sense of
from him of what that family what the
Nixon men were like and what that family
was like and he's a geologist a
scientist and I believe and so doesn't
have the most sophisticated view of
politics but has this really sort of
keen Nixonian wry sense of humor and it
was it was very enlightening to me best
best interview I did and I which is what
one other reason why I wish Julie would
and Tricia would sit down and just do
oral histories for the library I mean if
you don't want to talk to 60 minutes sit
down and do an oral history to the
library what do you think of the Frank
Gannon interviews and how many have them
more there there there were six six nine
something like that he was a friend of
and I were getting with the ghosts right
now Frank doesn't like the word ghost
writer he was the ghost writer the the
writing assistant for the memoirs along
with Diane Sawyer and and helped him
write write the memoirs and then they
decided to have Nixon sit down and and
Frank got him to open up on many
subjects it's the first time it's the
only place I for example I remember
Nixon calling himself paranoid about
leaks and about the press here he is and
just a short clip about the resignation
well after the speech I went over to the
residence Henry was very very thoughtful
he he came up to Minnie so they'd like
to walk
to the residents with me said I've
always done this after the big the
important speeches and as we got to the
door of the residence he said mr.
president history is going to record
that you were a great president I said
Henry that'll depend on who writes the
history went down Billy
Lincoln Rome and made a few calls to
people heard the chanting outside
reminded me of the Vietnam days except
this time the chant was jailed the chief
jail to the chief didn't bother me
however you know after all I'd been
heckled by experts you know there's a
footnote in there and I'm sorry I don't
have it to read it it was great about
that Clinton said he loved the fact that
he will always be famous
even as the only President to resign
even recounting those than those those
events he's delighted by the idea that
this nobody kid from Yorba Linda so
dominated the world stage and so
dominated history in the 20th century
you know even though it ended badly for
him
so badly for him and caused him such
grief and almost killed him you know is
a part of Nixon who was who was like boy
I showed him but there is a footnote
dating here again in the back where you
say is quoting Henry Kissinger saying he
didn't like him because he didn't like
him again liking Kissinger had had a
well first of all Kissinger was a great
example of Nixon being able to either
instinctively or or brilliantly find
somebody and pluck him and make him his
tool and Nixon and Kissinger probably
lasted with Haldeman probably lasted as
long as longer than than anybody and
Kissinger was very very good at what he
did I'm I have a basic argument with the
two of them over Vietnam that I carry
out throughout the Vietnam chapters but
there's no denying that they saw the
split between Russia and China of the
Soviet Union in China and decided that
they would exploit it the way that they
did and this led to the opening of China
and changed our world forever
and probably did I mean Nixon's goal in
China was to give us a couple of decades
of peace and he probably gave us maybe
50 years of peace but if Henry Kissinger
is quoted as saying he didn't like him
he'd been it was a phony two whole time
then because all the tapes show him
kissing up after speeches and mr.
president you're the greatest and it's
somewhere in those three volumes of
memoirs Kissinger actually says it you
know perfectly she has a great way of
like witty self-deprecating nod towards
the obvious and and he makes a crack
somewhere about the fact that yeah you
know the worst thing about these tapes
when they came out it's going to be that
they're going to show me as I kiss up
and and in some cases he was just he was
just awful
did he it had it was it's a flow of
Nixon is that he that he needed this to
did he did he talk to you know Kissinger
did not talk but again with with Henry
Kissinger
he's written probably five or six
volumes of books on the next ten years
and and talked repeatedly given speeches
and so there was a limit as to what I
could have asked him that could have you
know should I have asked him one more
time are you a war criminal Roger stone
who worked for Richard Nixon and has a
huge tattoo on his back of Richard
Nixon's face was here recently talking
about his own book let's watch what he
has to say about Richard Nixon and
Donald Trump the first person to imagine
a trump presidency was not me but was
former President Richard Nixon I was
working for Nixon doing political chores
in his post presidential years and he
met Donald Trump in George
Steinbrenner's box at Yankee Stadium and
they hit it off and he called me the
next day and he said well I met your man
I got to tell you he's got it he could
really go all the way Roger was very
righteous sat down and Roger private did
not Roger public and Rogers private sat
down with me and gave me a very helpful
interview about his experience with
Nixon but I it's a difference in private
private and public well Roger in his
books Roger on on television is more of
a show man
but he can also speak quietly to you and
talk to you about Nixon with with debts
and insight I don't believe that I think
that's it you know like I told you about
Clarence Darrow I think you know people
over time can convince themselves to
believe what they want to believe you
don't believe Roger stone story or you
don't believe the fact that it Richard
Nixon said that yeah I don't
it's just it's too it's a stretch for me
to believe that Roger stone would end up
working for Donald Trump all these years
later and remember that Richard Nixon
met Donald Trump in the box at Yankee
Stadium and came back one day and said
he's going to be President one day
because American history is filled by an
I can't take hundreds of relatives all
sat in their kitchen one day and said to
aunt Bertha across the table not you on
deck he's a piece of bright guy and
someday he's going to be President
everybody predicts presidents are going
to be presidents and a lot of your wit
whittier oral histories have people
quoted about that that and after the
fact again you didn't answer a question
I asked you earlier no it was really
about where did you write this what was
your what was your base my base was here
I live off the Beltway near the Mormon
temple and I did but how did you set it
up did you all this material you had to
know and a commencement is online I mean
somebody the other day wrote in an
entire book on camera what the topic was
but only online and it is sat in their
kitchen and all the research that they
needed was online and we're getting
there all of Clarence Darrell's papers
became
put online after unfortunately after I
went around the country finding them but
in in 20 or 30 years the problem is is
that they can't put everything that's at
the Nixon Library on I would it would it
will take 200 years so what you tend to
do is you tend if you're too lazy you'll
only do the online stuff you'll only do
the oral
sisters that are online and only did the
c-span I mean I spent hours watching
c-span archives you have a lot about
Nixon on c-span and but if you only do
that then you don't get into some of the
texture that can only be done by turning
every page so but there but in both the
Darrow and not so much in the tip books
but the Darrow and the Nixon book an
awful lot is online
all right maybe I'm fair question last
question ah if you were going to pick a
chapter in this book that everybody
should read that is no different unusual
which one would it be
it doesn't have the additional stuff
which is the big historical piece of the
puzzle that I contributed but I think
the the piece on the Cambodian incursion
in the spring of 1970 that chapter is
relatively short it's got lots of new
stuff it's got some great quotes from
the tapes that I came across that nobody
had had gotten before I liked that one
and I also I also loved the 1946
campaign which opens the book